und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
Siebers guten Abend Fußball Länderspiel
Deutschland Türkei
2:3 das ist das rein sportliche Ergebnis
des heutigen Abends im Berliner
Olympiastadion aber natürlich gibt es da
noch viel mehr Fußball der auch
politisch ist und viel sagt über unser
Land und unsere Gesellschaft kapit der
deutschen Nationalmannschaft ist einer
dessen Eltern aus der Türkei kommen im
ausverkauften Stadion auch viele Fans
die in Deutschland geboren sind hier
leben aber die Türkei anfeuern und dann
wirkt der Besuch des türkischen
Staatspräsidenten in Berlin nach wie
Stefan Merseburger und Markus groß
berichten sie zünden Pyros Knallkörper
und Raketen bringen sich in fah der
Marsch verläuft weitgehend störungsfrei
es sieht aus wie eine Machtdemonstration
das wurde so erwartet Fans der
türkischen Mannschaft auf dem Weg ins
Olympia Stadion die meisten haben einen
deutschen Pass ne ich hoffe dass
natürlich Türkei gewinnt aber wenn
Türkei nicht gewinnt ist es auch nicht
schlimm wir sind hier geboren wir leben
hier daher soll ein ferpiel werden ich
bin in dem Land geboren aber
ursprünglich bin ich aus der Türkei und
das macht es so ganz besonders die
Türkei kommt nichtes hier nach
Deutschland hin und wir sind jetzt knapp
450 km gefahren um dieses Spiel hier
anzuschauen und bisschen Stimmung hier
zu
machen politisch ist die Stimmung
zwischen Deutschland und der Türkei
momentan angespannt der Nahostkonflikt
belastet die Beziehungen und auch das
Freundschaftsspiel man stellt das immer
so da dass es angespannt ist aber die
Leute die hier miteinander leben sind
alles cool coole Leute wir sind eine
Familie alles sehr relaxte Stimmung in
der U-Bahn viel Gespräche geführt hier
viele Gespräche geführt ich ich denke es
keine besondere Brisanz jetzt politisch
gesehen persönlich brisant ist die
Partie für ilkai gündowan er spielt zum
ersten Mal gegen die Heimat seiner
Eltern und das als Deutscher Kapitän
zwei Herzen schlagen in seiner Brust
seine Familie se elternleben in der
Türkei natürlich ist es besonderer
Moment für ihn ich glaube es ganz normal
aber es freut sich auf dieses Spiel er
hat SP auf Verantwortung gutes Spiel zu
machen das liegt auch auf der Hand
deutsche Nationalspieler mit türkischen
Wurz stehen unter besonderer Beobachtung
und werden gerne politisch vereinnaht
nach dem 3:0 in der EM Qualifikation
gegen die Türkei 2010 besuchte Kanzlerin
Merkel Mesut ösil in der Umkleidekabine
ein willkommenes Symbol für politische
Integration das ist eine zesur in der
politischen Kultur Deutschlands und da
hat eine große Politisierung dieser
Frage stattgefunden 2018 ist der
türkische Präsident Erdogan im Wahlkampf
die Bilder mit Weltmeister ösil sind
Despoten willkommene Propaganda auch
gündan war dabei er distanzierte sich
später ösil nicht Politik und Fußball
ein Minenfeld auf dem Spielfeld musste
gündewan heute einiges
einstecken Deutschland geht in einem
torreichen Spiel durch Kai harwz in
Führung insgesamt fallen fünf Treffer im
ausverkauften Olympiastadion in der 70
Minute handelf für die
Türkei verwandelt zum 2:3 Endstand einer
emotionalen Begegnung bittere Niederlage
für Deutschland und ein großer
prestigewinn für die
Türkei wo sollen wir noch hin das ist
die verzweifelte Frage heute in Gaza wo
Israels Armee begonnen hat auch den
Südteil unter Beschuss zu nehmen exakt
den Teil in den 100taus geflohen waren
weil Israels Armee sie angewiesen hatte
den Nordteil zu verlassen
bringt sie zurück jetzt das ist der
verzweifelte Aufruf von zigtausenden
heute in Israel Familienangehörige von
Geiseln die Hamas Terroristen
verschleppt haben demonstrieren mit
einem Marsch entlang der wichtigsten
Autobahn von der Küste Richtung
Jerusalem und versuchen so den Druck auf
ihre Regierung zu erhöhen aus Tel Aviv
Dominik
lesmeister Tel Aviv am Abend die
Angehörigen und Freunde der Geiseln
versammeln sich vor dem ver
sind
tausab traf heute Abend zwei Mitglieder
des kriegskabinetts er kämpft um die
Freilassung seiner jüngeren Schwester
Chan entführt von der Hamas am 7
Oktober wir denken dass wir als Familien
und Angehörige der entführten und
Vermissten ein Wort mitzureden haben wir
sollten in die Entscheidungen mit
einbezogen werden oder zumindest
informiert werden was bisher nicht
geschieht
am Mittag war der Protestmarsch in
Jerusalem angekommen mit transparenten
der über 230 von der Hamas entführten
bringt sie nach Haus fordern sie die
Familien machen Druck auf Israels
Ministerpräsidenten netanah der die
Angehörigen heute nicht getroffen hat
sich auf der Pressekonferenz aber ganz
pathetisch
gibt wir laufen mit euch ich laufe mit
euch ganz Israel läuft mit euch deine
Lieben sind in unseren Herzen stehen vor
unseren Augen die ganze
Zeit es bleibt dabei Waffenruhe nur bei
Rückführung der Geiseln Israel verstärkt
den militärischen Druck auf die Hamas
greift immer mehr Ziele im Süden des
Gazastreifens an Luftangriffe auf
hananunis die zweitgrößte Stadt des
Gazastreifens in der hunderttausende
Palästinenser aus dem Norden Zuflucht
Suen sie graben mit bloßen Händen suchen
nach Überlebenden dutzende sollen
getötet worden sein so die
palästinensische Seite unabhängig
überprüfen lässt sich das nicht der
Süden von dem netanyaho der Welt sagt es
sei ein sicheres Gebiet plötzlich hören
wir
raketeneinschläge aus dem Schifer
Krankenhaus flüchten die Menschen
Richtung Süden unklar ist wer das
veranlasst hat Israel sagt die
Evakuierung geschehe auf Wunsch der
Klinik die Palästinenser sprechen von
Zwang viele sind
verzweelt gehen Ken wir wissen es nicht
wo es sicher ist ich bin zum ersten Mal
hier in der Gegend ich kenne mich nicht
aus möge Gott uns
beschützen es ist überall nur tot ich
trage meinen Sohn auf den Schultern und
meine Frau ist schwanger um 6 Uhr
morgens sind wir los es gab kein Essen
kein trinken kein Leben wir wissen noch
nicht wohin wir
gehen so wirft Israels Luftwaffe heute
über einigenen Süden des Gazastreifens
Flugblätter ab mit der Aufforderung das
Gebiet zu verlassen Richtung Westen
Richtung
Küste interessant ist wie der
US-Präsident sich jetzt gemeldet hat zur
Zukunft von Gaza Joe Biden schreibt in
der Washington Post Gaza und das
Westjordanland sollten wieder vereinigt
werden und zwar mit einer einzigen
Regierungsstruktur nämlich und ich
zitiere ihn da mit letztlich einer neu
aufgestellten palästinensischen
Autonomiebehörde
wie die USA an diesem Ziel künftig
Arbeiten wird jetzt genau zu beobachten
sein ein neues Logo eine neue Kampagne
es soll ein neues Kapitel sein so stellt
sich das die Führung der Linken auf
ihrem Parteitag vor das alte Kapitel ist
ja gerade erst ziemlich dramatisch zu
Ende gegangen die Bundestagsfraktion hat
angekündigt sich selbst aufzulösen
nachdem eine Gruppe um Sarah Wagenknecht
ausgetreten war ein lange schwelender
Streit ist damit erstmal vom Tisch die
Probleme für die Partei allerdings noch
lange nicht Dorte
Ferber sie ist das neue Gesicht der
Linken für die Europawahl seotretterin
und klimaaktivistin Carola Rakete soll
junge Wähler
ansprechen wir streiten für ein Europa
der Solidarität und genau deshalb
kandidiere ich für die Linke weil sie
die einzige ist die die soziale Frage
nicht gegen die ökologische
ausspielt weiter ohne Wagenknecht die
Linke will sie muss in Augsburg ein
Zeichen setzen ganz ohne klar geht das
nicht ein
wagenknechtanhänger nutzt seine Redezeit
für eine
Schimpftirade und da ist die Fraktion in
Auflösung eine Niederlage bilanziert
dimar Barsch nach dem Abgang von
Wagenknecht und ihren Leuten ist
enttäuschend und es ist auch
verantwortungslos Liebe Genossin und
genossen aber eins will ich auch sagen
die Botschaft dieses Parteitages muss
ganz klar sein es ist Schluss mit der
lehenden Selbstbeschäftigung es ist
endgültig Schluss wir wollen ein
politisches comeb der
Linken ein neues Logo eine neue Kampagne
sollen die Linke nach vorne bringen und
eine klare Positionierung 15 €
Mindestlohn höhere Steuern offene
Migrationspolitik bei der aushüllung des
Asylrechts da gilt in der Tat da wollen
wir nicht grüner werden als gr we wir
haben weil wir Haltung ze und das
aslrecht
Verteidigen die Lage der Partei aber
bleibt prekh die aktuellen
Umfrageergebnisse bescheiden es gibt ein
paar hundert Neueintritte nach dem
Abgang vom Wagenknecht und Co nur fehlen
eben Promis also
fast ich nehme diesen Augsburger
Parteitag als etwas Besonderes war dass
ich nämlich genau die Jüngeren stimmen
hier schon
spüreossen gest ein
te Einigung in einerstrittenen Frage der
Linken kein großer Streit das werten sie
nach zwei Tagen Augsburg schon als
Gewinn also ich bin der Meinung dass wir
mit einem einfachen weiter so und noch
ein bisschen fleißiger es nicht schaffen
werden als Linke unsere gute Arbeit
fortzusetzen ich denke dass wir alle
gerade dabei sind um die richtige
Haltung zu ringen also aufbstimmung sagt
sich immer so leicht aber ich glaube für
viele ist riesige Erleichterung dass es
zusammen weitergt ine Erwartungen das
ist DIE LINKE nach wagenkncht Programm
ohne Prominenz und Hoffnung auf bessere
Zeiten so und was sonst noch wichtig ist
an diesem
Samstagabend jetzt bei dir Hanna
bundesinnenministerin fer hat den
Auftritt eines afghanischen
talibanfunktionärs in einer Kölner
dietipmoschee als vollkommen
inakzeptabel kritisiert und Aufklärung
gefordert niemand dürfe radikalen
Islamisten in Deutschland eine Bühne
bieten erklärt fer weiter die dietip
distanzierte sich von dem Auftritt des
talibanvertreters der am Donnerstagabend
stattgefunden hatte unklar ist wie der
Mann überhaupt nach Deutschland
einreisen
konnte nach dem haushaltsurteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts mehren sich
die Forderungen nach einer Aussetzung
der Schuldenbremse die Chefin der
Wirtschaftsweisen Schnitzer sprach sich
gegenüber der reinischen Post dafür aus
ähnlich äußerten sich SPD Parteichef in
esken sowie der deutsche Gewerkschaft
Bund karlsruhe hatte am Mittwoch
entschieden dass 60 Milliarden Euro zur
Bekämpfung der coronapandemie nicht
nachträglich in den Klima und
transformationsfond verschoben werden
dürfen in der spanischen Hauptstadt
Madrid sind heute laut behehörden rund
170.000 Menschen auf die Straße gegangen
um gegen die geplante Amnestie für
katalanische Separatisten zu
demonstrieren massive Kritik richtete
sich gegen den am Donnerstag
wiedergewählten Ministerpräsident z
dieser hatte sich mit dem
hochumstrittenen Amnestiegesetz im
Parlament die Mehrheit für seine weitere
Amtszeit gesichert gegen Sanchez Pläne
gibt es in Spanien seit Wochen
Proteste auch der zweite Testflug der
unbemannten Starship Rakete des
Raumfahrtunternehmen SpaceX von
Milliardär Elon Musk ist
fehlgeschlagen kurz nach dem Start
trennten sich zwar beide Raketenstufen
erfolgreich dann aber dennoch habe man
mehr Erkenntnisse gesammelt als beim
ersten Fehlversuch im April hieß es die
usraumfahrt behehörde NASA will mit der
größten jemals gebauten Rakete künftig
Astronauten auf den Mond
befördern zu den Lottozahlen an diesem
Samstag die lauten 10 18 23 27 28 38
Superzahl 4 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewehr noch die Wetter Aussichten morgen
im Osten und Süden anfangs noch Regen
sonst neben vielen Schauern auch längere
trockene Abschnitte 9 bis
15° auch die neue Woche startet mild und
wechselhaft mit Regen und nur wenig
Sonne am Mittwoch dann Kühler
freundlicher und nur noch am Alpenrand
Schnee
Regenschauer da freuen wir uns drauf ich
weiß schon komm noch wie das aussieht
Sonne und wir sagen DANKE für heute gern
bis morgen dann wieder gewohnt um 21:5
40 einen schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
tschüss